I've been requested to do some
more implicit differentiation
or differentiation of implicit
functions by I believe his name
is [? Akash ?], so I
will do some more.
And these are actually the
problems that he sent to me and
they looked good, so those
are the ones I'll do.
The first problem he gave me,
and I'll do it in green, says y
to the third power minus xy
squared plus cosine
xy is equal to 2.
So like all differentiation of
implicit functions-- and of
course in these examples I'm
going to-- except for the last
one-- I'm going to find
the derivative of y
with respect to x.
So in all of these I
want to figure out what
dy/dx is equal to.
Well to do that just like in
the previous video we just take
the derivative with respect to
x on both sides of
this equation.
So we do the derivative
operator I guess
we could call it.
So we're going to take
it on this side.
ddx.
And we're going to take the
derivative of everything.
Then we're going to take the
derivative on the right hand
side, the derivative of 2,
which we know hopefully
by this point is 0.
And I'll do it a little bit
quicker than in last video, but
anyway send me a note if you
think I did it too fast.
So let's take the derivative
of each of these terms.
So the derivative with
respect to x of y cubed.
Well it's the derivative with
respect to y, we're just
doing the chain rule.
So it's 3y-- that's a y,
not a g-- 3y squared.
So the derivative of this
function with respect to y
times the derivative of
y with respect to x.
dy/dx.
That's just the chain rule.
And then we have minus
the derivative of this
with respect to x.
Well this is a little
interesting, because here we
have x times y squared, which
we're arguing is maybe a
function of what's an
implicit function of x.
So how do we do that?
What we'll do-- let me put the
subtraction sign outside and
then let's do the derivative
inside, and I'll do it
inside some brackets.
So let's do the
product rule here.
We have x times y squared.
The product rule says it's the
derivative of the first
function times a second
function plus the derivative of
the second function times
the first function.
So the derivative of the first
function with respect to x--
remember what we're taking the
derivative with respect to--
well the derivative
of x is just 1.
1 times y squared plus
the derivative of
the second function.
Well what's the derivative
of the second function?
Well it's going to be 2y
dy/dx, and that just comes
from the chain rule.
The derivative with respect
to y times the derivative
of y with respect to x.
That's the chain rule.
So that's the derivative of y
squared, and then we multiply
that times the first
function, which is x.
Times x.
Hopefully that
didn't confuse you.
Just took the derivative
of x times y squared.
This is the product rule.
Plus the derivative
of y squared, which
was this times x.
OK now we're ready to move on.
OK.
Now this is interesting.
This is interesting.
We have to take the
derivative of cosine of xy.
Well once again we just
do the chain rule.
And maybe I'll actually break
it up into a couple of steps
here just so that you don't
get completely confused.
So what does the chain rule say
if we have you know f of g
of x of whatever whatever?
We essentially have to take the
derivative of the inside
function and multiply-- or well
I guess you could
do it two ways.
You could say we take the
entire derivative with respect
to whatever this function is.
You know if g was equal to xy
we could say the derivative of
cosine of g with respect to g.
And then we would multiply
that times the derivative
of this with respect to x.
If that confuses you, I think
it'll make more sense when
I actually do the example.
Actually let me write out like
just the way I said it, because
I think that could maybe even
clear up some confusion
over the chain rule.
Or maybe it'll
confuse you further.
So what are we doing?
We're going to do the
derivative-- let me do this
in a different color.
So let's take derivative
of the outside function
with respect to xy.
So what is that?
What's the derivative
of cosine of x?
Or let's say if it was
g is equal to xy.
If g is equal to xy, then
that expression there
is cosine of g.
So what's the derivative of
this with respect to g?
Sorry, dg.
Well that's just minus
sin of g, right?
So let me do that in
a different color.
So it's minus sin,
and g was just xy.
So that's the derivative
of you can kind of say
of the outside function.
And then we go to the inside,
and we have to multiply this
times the derivative of
this inside function.
Let me just write
that like this.
Times the derivative with
respect to x--that's what
we're doing-- of xy.
And I'm going to leave it
like that for now because
that's going to take a
little bit of space.
And then that equals
the derivative of 2
with respect to x.
Well 2 never changes, right?
It's a constant, so
it's derivative is 0.
Let's see if we can simplify
this a little bit, and
we'll come back to that,
let's just write this.
So we have 3g-- no I'm
confusing myself with
my bad penmanship.
3y-- all that talk of g
got me confused-- dy/dx.
3y squared dy/dx minus y
squared minus-- I'm just
distributing the minus--
xy minus 2xy dy/dx
minus sin of xy.
And then this whole thing
times the derivative of
xy with respect to x.
Well we can just do the
product rule here.
What's the derivative of
xy with respect to x?
Well the derivative of x
is 1, so it's 1 times y.
Derivative of the first
times the second function.
Plus the derivative of
the second function
with respect to x.
So what's the derivative
of y with respect to x?
Well it's just dy/dx, right?
dy/dx times the first function.
That's just the product rule.
Review of the product rule if
that was a little confusing.
It's equal to 0.
And now we can
attempt to simplify.
So let's see if I can do it.
So we have 3y squared
dy/dx minus y squared
minus 2xy dy/dx.
Now this one's interesting,
so let me distribute
the sin of xy.
This is just a 1, so it's minus
y sin of xy minus x dy/dx sin
of xy-- I'm just simplifying,
this is just algebra.
So y is equal to 0.
Now let's group all of the
terms that have a dy/dx in them
and distribute out the dy/dx.
So this is equal to dy/dx times
this 3y squared minus two xy.
I'm just undistributing where
I'm dividing out the dy/dx.
So let me actually
show you the terms.
So this has a dy/dx,
this has a dy/dx.
And this is just algebra.
This has a dy/dx, so let
me separate those out.
So it's 3y squared minus
2xy minus x sin of xy.
Well that's all of the ones
with the dy/dx on them.
And then these terms-- and I'm
just skipping a couple of
steps because this is
algebra right now.
The non dy/dx terms-- that
term, and I guess there's only
two of them-- I'm just going
to add to the other
side of equation.
So I'm just going to bring
them over to the other side.
Hopefully that step
doesn't confuse you.
This is just algebraic
simplification at this point.
I could have written minus y
squared minus y sin xy and then
added them on the other side,
but I'm about to run out of
space and time, so I'm just
going to add these to both
sides of the equation.
So that equals y squared
plus y sin of xy.
I think I've covered
all of the terms.
And now since our goal is to
find the derivative of y with
respect to x, we can divide
both sides of this equation by
this term right here, and our
final answer is-- let me
do it in a good color.
dy/dx.
The derivative of y with
respect to x is equal to that
y squared plus y sin of xy
divided by this-- 3y squared
minus 2xy minus x sin of xy.
And there you have it.
That was a good implicit
differentiation problem and if
you understood how to do that,
you understand how to do
implicit differentiation.
And I hope I didn't make any
careless mistakes, and it's a
good exercise for you to try
to do it again on your own.
See you soon.